[Music]
[Music]
now i just wanted to set the story
straight and not waste anyone's time if
you keep an eye on the latest updates
from massive or ubisoft there may be not
too much in the way of news in here for
you
this is more for the rapidly increasing
number of questions i'm getting around
the division where i'm going with it and
why i'm not talking about it too much
right now
legitimately every video i put out has
comments saying yeah that's cool but
what about the division and of course
there are the less chill comments
basically getting angry with me for
talking about other games that i enjoy
a lot of people seem to think that i
have inside knowledge or a direct line
to the divs i really don't
i have the same information everyone
else can find the only real difference
is that i'm probably a little more
obsessive in searching and reading up on
things than most which we won't get into
right now in fear of incriminating
myself even further
ubisoft have clearly decided that the
division as an ip is something that they
see value in and would like to continue
to invest in
recently we've had the hearts on fire
audio drama it was good i thought the
acting and writing was actually really
well done i probably would have
preferred if they'd released it over
time rather than five plus hours at once
but i found it thoroughly entertaining
there were a few bits to the story i
felt were a little bit off but that's
probably just me digging a little deeper
than was intended by the author
we have a new comic coming out
technically this isn't actually new as
it was first released in 2019 in france
but the english version is coming out in
december 2021
i'm not actually a huge comic book
person myself but when i break down what
i'm reading and extract what i find
interesting in the story i actually
really enjoy the different style and
direction that content like extremist
malice have added to the overall
narrative direction
[Music]
obviously there's also the division
mobile game as well as i've discussed
there's so much potential here but i'm
not holding my breath
the next novel was also announced and as
we can see from akronitebooks.com this
will be titled tom clancy's the division
recruited unlike the other two division
novels this one has been written by
thomas parrott and will be available
globally february 1st 2022
i'll have a link to this in the
description but the preface describes
the story
a newly recruited agent is the shd's
best hope to prevent a nefarious plot
from ripping the agency apart
maira kanhai has had enough
since the green poison epidemic hit dc
her cyber security degree is worthless
she can't rejoin the us navy and her
early efforts to secure maryland led to
a costly mistake the death of her
brother
every day new factions emerge trying to
burn her city to the ground until the
division emerges inspiring hope when a
grenade kills one of their agents mira
suddenly has a chance to make a real
difference as a raw new division recruit
if she can pass the tests and overcome
the enemy's plotting to permanently
eliminate the division once and for all
[Music]
of course then there's the movie
starring jessica chastain and jake
gyllenhaal that is still progressing
along nicely
i still haven't had a chance to have my
catch up with director rawson thurber
not through any fault of his more so
myself
contrary to popular belief this isn't my
full-time job i have a day job that i
love and a family of almost five that i
support with an amazing wife and
manager any married man watching this
understands where i'm coming from here
so my flexibility is pretty abysmal to
say the least and being on opposite
sides of the planet have made this a
little challenging but i'll sort this
eventually
what i can say is that rawson has been
reaching out and replying to the
community on a number of different
things that have only fit into the
confidence of the fantastic production
in the long run
back in april rawson could be seen
asking the community of the make and
model of the dz helicopter
something that most probably wouldn't
care about but it's super awesome to see
the detail he's looking into
also in may he responded to someone
asking of the possibility of cosplayers
to be included in the film as extras
his response
considered doable and planned
details to follow
i haven't yet spoken to the guy yet but
based on his interactions with the
community and the feedback i had from
fellow division enthusiast born diesel
he sounds bloody awesome
given that he's talking about the
possibility of using cosplay community
members in the film maybe he'd be keen
on some other community input
i know i'm a man in his mid-thirties
with a dead body to suit but i have a
stunning resemblance to aaron kina
and a voice that i've been told aligns
well with the division story
maybe i could be a malfunctioning isaac
struggling with a language translation
oh bro there's lots of angry dudes over
there
cheers
damn it someone started petition for me
let's make this happen
the division heartlands without spoiling
too much is looking to be a new
stand-alone battle royale-ish type game
i haven't tried it myself but from what
i've seen it could hold some promise of
a decent game time will tell
and then of course we can't forget about
the acclaimed crossover that the
division has had with xdefiant where two
of the hostile factions make an
appearance
some of you may already be aware of my
thoughts behind this one if you watch
the video yeah i'll put the link there
but
be warned it was certainly a different
type of content for me
while all of these additions to the
division universe are cool most of us
are still left wondering what is
happening to the core game of the series
the last update we were given was a
message from almost six months ago
in the next major update we're looking
to bring in a game mode that's entirely
new to the franchise
along with the game mode we are
investigating new ways to progress your
agent with an emphasis on increasing
build variety and viability
we will be revealing more about what
lies ahead as the update gets closer
the development of this new update is
still in its early stages and will take
several months to complete as a result
our next major update is currently
scheduled for release late 2021 at its
earliest we will be taking this time to
make sure we bring a meaningful change
to the game
given that we're nearing the end of 2021
and we've still heard nothing people
understandably are starting to get
impatient
for a live service game updates are
usually provided far more frequently
than what we're seeing here
or at the very least there would be open
lines of communication like we used to
have with the state of the game
whether you liked it or hated it it was
still good to see the studio investing
this time into communicating with the
fans of the game
so the big question on everyone's mind
right now is what are the future plans
for the game
if any
we know massive entertainment are
working heavily on avatar and star wars
projects
the majority of people in the know
expected them to either be shutting down
the division or passing it off to
another ubisoft studio
but the announcement six months ago said
no
there is still more to come
however we didn't see the division at e3
this year and there wasn't even anyone
from the division community who was
nominated as one of the star players
it can be easy to blame it on the world
by pandemic and i'd say this definitely
had a big impact initially but games
like destiny and warframe seem to be
well back on track for new content
releases
even outriders and they don't even
consider their product a live service
game
[Music]
the division seems to be a bit of a
weird one for ubisoft
it's no secret that the division 2
didn't perform quite as well as ubisoft
would have liked on release
yet well enough that we're seeing all
these spin-offs being added to the
universe
but it would seem they're unwilling to
invest quite the same of resource into
the future of the core game that we've
seen in the past if the game is coming
to an end that's fine just let us know
and stop stringing everyone along
if not great but perhaps it would be a
good time to start following the
traditions of other games in the genre
that provide road maps and steady
updates to the community of what is
being worked on and what is to come
for a live service game silence will
never be taken in the most positive
light
this video ended up being a little more
honest than i'd initially planned don't
get me wrong i freaking love this game
from the moment i started reading into
everything long before it was released
and even longer before i started making
content on it i was obsessed with the
world they had created
obviously i don't want to see the game
die but i'm old enough these days to
understand that if this isn't feasible
from a business sense then it could be
time to wrap it up
i just rather ended quickly if this is
the plan as not to leave a bitter taste
as my last memories regardless of what
happens i'll keep you up to date with my
thoughts on what's to come
hopefully this answers the many
questions i've been getting
i actually have a number of scripts
written up but i hadn't thought of them
to be worthy of recording and uploading
i might have a second look at them and
see what i think now
otherwise i'm gonna go back to killing
my hardcore characters over and over
solo hardcore is life i just wish i was
better at it
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]